a joyful roar greeted Angela miracle at
the headquarters of her CDU party in
Berlin many had been expecting they'd
score a victory but a sweeping landslide
like this was beyond their boldest hopes
the result a resounding endorsement for
Chancellor Merkel and her policies dear
friends your cheers show us that we can
all celebrate this is a super result I'd
like to thank the voters who have given
us so clearly their trust and I can
promise them we will treat that trust
responsibly many here were disappointed
about losing their coalition partner the
FDP
it looks like they're going to be booted
out of the Bundestag and out of the
government but the scale of the CDU zone
victory tempered any sadness as did the
knowledge that this win was due in large
part to the Chancellor herself
Chancellor Merkel is very popular she
has good policies she's mrs. Europe we
have to thank her for this victory
wonderful a super result I didn't expect
it stunning it's a result we can tell
our grandchildren about and say we were
there the final result may mean an
absolute majority for Uncle America's
Conservatives or a grand coalition with
the Social Democrats whatever the
outcome Chancellor Merkel can rest
assured she delivered exactly what her
party wanted guys enjoy it and that joy
will give us the strength to govern well
in the years to come
we have great responsibility but we can
deal with that all the very very best
thank you Doug